of the 30 major league baseball teams 26
have infield mixes sourced from
here all right so this is what we're
after the beginnings of a baseball field
all the hard work crushing rock all for
this right here this right here is
Pittsburgh red bed and this claystone is
unique in how it reacts to one key
element water for the owners of the
teams it's about playing in the rain you
equate it to monetizing what the cost of
the infield was versus playing a game in
the rain water's very important because
it absorbs the ball bounce almost like
corkboard but just getting to the clay
can take 2 months here's how a single
dirt farm takes all of this to turn into
this it all starts here 300 million
years ago sediment from eroding
mountains deposited this unique Rock
unit called The Glen Shaw formation and
the Pittsburgh red bed is hidden within
it we have to remove all the overburden
above it the Sandstone the gray Shale
and then a limestone layer that's about
a foot thick at the bottom the
overburden becomes thicker at higher
elevations so Dura edge products can
only mine for the clay here otherwise
it's cost prohibitive to mine the clay
because you have too much overburden to
take off the top it cost too much money
Pittsburgh redbed is predominantly made
up of ilite and cite two clay minerals
that can absorb water without swelling
and dissipate the water quickly as you
can see this material is very densely
packed so we have to take it up to the
plant and crush it to make it a usable
product for baseball fields over the
course of a year excavators will mine
and then load approximately 30,000 tons
of the clay into these trucks driving it
all to a processing facility an hour
away the challenge to this business is
taking something that's this hard
compressed in the ground and then
ultimately we want to get it into that
powder we want to Mill it into something
like talcum powder the clay is
pre-crushed with a bulldozer then
reduced down to an inch and a half half
thanks to this
bucket it's got hammers on the inside
and teeth that grab the clay and
physically smash
it finally the clay is pushed through a
Remco Crusher it's a vertical shaft
impact Crusher and it spins at 1,800
RPMs between that bucket and that
Crusher it's made the product perform so
much better but transforming the clay
into infield mix requires a specific
proportion of clay silt and sand the
sand creates void space the silt and
Clay fill the void space when it's in
the proper ratio and that requires the
use of a pug mill which is back here
behind
us so what happens when you put it
through the pugmill you build friction
inside the mixer and when you grind the
two products together the clay will
actually adhere into the sand and it
comes out as one single homogeneous mix
the company creates three types of
infield mix that vary in proportions
professional grade infield mix has less
sand and more clay content which helps
retain more moisture better but also
requires more maintenance this is a
finished product once you smooth it off
you can tell there's anything in there
if the Sand's too fine I can tell it
won't hold together quite as well if the
Sand's too coarse the coarse particles
will stick out when I'm testing my
product and I've got the right moisture
in it I can go like this with my product
it'll stay together you could almost
juggle I don't know how to juggle but
you could you could juggle these balls
right but then when I when I drop it on
the ground I want that ball to just
completely fall apart so then I'll I'll
go like this and I'll pack it down and
ultimately when it's compressed that's
what the surface is going to look like
stadiums nearby will have their infield
mix delivered from the main processing
facility for stadiums farther away only
the clay is shipped and the infield mix
is made at one of dura Edge's satellite
locations saving up to 70% in freight
costs it cuts down tremendously on
Logistics costs because if you were to
make it all here and ship it to Salt
Lake City you would be shipping five
more trucks and the cost of that would
be too great there are some
groundskeepers that want things made
slightly different but by and large
we're producing the exact same product
for every team like at City Field City
Field infield mix is actually very
similar to a lot of the other ballparks
sometimes regionally they differ
slightly just based on the weather
that's a big factor for us here is how
our infield mix performs in different
weather conditions hot humid dry wet
rainy you know we're trying to get it
the same every day building a Major
League Baseball infield from scrap
requires up to 350 tons of infield mix
which can cost anywhere from $50,000 to
$80,000 so many stadiums focus on
maintenance incorporating smaller
deliveries into their existing infield
as needed what's going to happen after
he's done scarifying is we're going to
add a little bit of material and the
laser grader is going to push the
material into all the little low spots
and cut from the high spots so that
everything's nice and level he is
actually finishing the grade of the
infield to within about an eighth of an
inch infields are required to be graded
so so that the baselines and the home
plates are level then a thin layer of
top dressing or conditioner is added to
help retain moisture and enhance the
sliding surface for players so this
machine right here is the final step
this is a 1 and 1/2 ton roller and this
will pack everything back down when
we're done laser grading after that a
little bit of water and we're good to go
the trick is to keep the infield
consistent every single game when an
infield mix isn't good it'll break apart
so as players are running around it
chunks will be coming out of or
something's acting up then we'll check
moisture meter and we have a range that
we like to get it's going to play well
in that range but grounds Keepers can
often check the moisture with one simple
trick if the key goes in and out nice
and smoothly then we know that it's
where it needs to be so the key goes in
it has a little bit of force and then it
comes out and there's no chunks it's
nice and clean water is very important
for an infield because it absorbs the
ball bounce it makes the infield mix
pliable and almost like
corkboard before soil science became
standard application in the MLB
ballparks teams relied on local
suppliers but grounds Keepers say
infield dirt then was inconsistent and
more difficult to maintain competing
infield mix suppliers say their products
achieve the same purpose without using
the specific clay but after starting
with the Philadelphia Phillies in 2005
Dura Edge product supplies most MLB
teams today it started to get out a bit
more around this part of the country
that you know I'm the dirt guy people
are incredibly surprised by the fact
that this is where it comes from and
Presto whmo you got infield mix that's
how it
works